[Música]
Irán suprime la policía de la moral
según anunció la fiscalía de Teherán una
de las principales demandas de las
protestas desatadas por la muerte de Max
mini bajo custodia de este cuerpo de la
fuerza pública encargado de controlar
las normas de comportamiento impuestas
en la República islámica
en la isla de Java Indonesia el volcán
semeru entró en erupción esta madrugada
las autoridades evacuaron a dos mil
personas y decretaron la alerta máxima
el año pasado la erupción del mismo
volcán causó 51 muertos
segunda fecha de octavos en Qatar
Francia se suma Argentina y Países Bajos
y pasa a cuartos de final tras vencer
3-1 a Polonia en el segundo partido del
día se enfrentan Inglaterra y senegal
conectamos con nuestro enviado especial
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Irán porque la
fiscalía general anunció el fin de la
policía de la moral la disolución de
este cuerpo de la fuerza pública ha sido
una de las principales demandas de las
masivas protestas anti gubernamentales
desatadas a raíz de la muerte de macsa
Mini el 16 de septiembre Y es que
recordemos que la joven falleció bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral que
la detuvo supuestamente pues no llevar
bien puesto el velo Samuel Salgado a
continuación nos cuenta más sobre esta
autoridad que desde la revolución
islámica de 1979 bajo distintos nombres
y formas ha controlado las estrictas
normas de comportamiento que rigen en el
país sobre todo para las mujeres
una decisión histórica en un régimen
teocrático el fiscal general de Irán
anunció el fin de la policía de la moral
la policía de la moral no tiene nada que
ver con el poder judicial y ha sido
abolidada Por quienes la crearon
un intento por sofocar tres meses de
protestas dentro y fuera del país que
dejan al menos 450 fallecidos luego de
la muerte de la joven kurda masamini
bajo custodia de esa fuerza por no
portar bien
Irán también anunció que revisa la ley
que desde 1983 exige que las mujeres
porten el velo y sin dar detalles el
presidente ebrahim Racing habló de
flexibilidad en la implementación de la
Constitución
los fundamentos islámicos y republicanos
dirán están arraigados
constitucionalmente pero existen métodos
para implementar la Constitución que
pueden ser flexibles
Según la ley a partir de los 7 años las
niñas deben usar el jiyab y todas las
mujeres desde la pubertad deben cubrirse
la cabeza y llevar ropa holgada en
público la policía de la moral
patrullaba las calles de Irán desde 2006
para hacer cumplir el código de
vestimenta Y aunque fue reformada en
2016 ilimitada a reportar infracciones
sin tomar decisiones definitivas ni
castigos en septiembre este año más a
mini fue arrestada y golpeada lo que
según grupos de derechos provocó su
muerte tres días después en un hospital
de Teherán dejando en evidencia casos de
violencia similares pese a los recientes
anuncios los manifestantes convocaron
para el lunes una huelga de tres días
con el objetivo de mantener la presión
sobre el régimen de los ayatolas
y en Siria decenas de manifestantes anti
gubernamentales asaltaron el
ayuntamiento de la ciudad de alsueida en
el sur del país según el Ministerio del
interior de Damasco un policía murió en
los enfrentamientos y el observatorio
sirio de Derechos Humanos reportó un
civil fallecido y otros siete heridos
además la misma organización señaló que
los participantes en las protestas
retiraron la imagen del presidente
gubernamental según la ONU el 88% de la
población de Siria no tiene acceso a
productos básicos
y esta madrugada en la isla de Java en
Indonesia entró en erupción el volcán
semeru las autoridades han evacuado a
2000 personas de la zona y han declarado
la alerta máxima hasta el momento se
desconoce si hay heridos o muertos como
consecuencia de la lava pero recordemos
que hace un año la última gran erupción
del monte semeru causó 51 fallecidos
veamos el informe
nubes de ceniza caliente de 15
kilómetros de altura
el monte semeru en Indonesia entró en
erupción una vez más enviando lava por
la montaña y cubriendo los pueblos
cercanos de ceniza caliente unas 2000
personas se vieron obligadas a huir
ahora llueve en mi pueblo y no se ve
nada llueve ceniza volcánica A dónde va
ahora no lo sé lo más importante es
subir del pueblo para salvar a mi
familia Esta última erupción en la isla
Indonesia de Java comenzó casi a las 3
de la madrugada hora local del domingo y
las labores de búsqueda y rescate están
en marcha las autoridades se elevaron el
nivel de alerta del volcán a 4 el más
alto que existe ante el temor de que se
produzcan más estallidos de nubes
calientes flujos de lava y
desprendimientos de escombros volcánicos
se advirtió a los residentes que
mantuvieran una distancia de 8
kilómetros del volcán y los evacuados
fueron trasladados a refugios
cuando sea seguro podemos pedirles que
vuelvan a sus casas pero si todavía no
es seguro tienen que quedarse en
nuestros refugios
la última gran erupción del monte semeru
hace un año mató al menos a 51 personas
el volcán es uno de los casi 130
volcanes activos de Indonesia y es el
más alto y uno de los que más registra
actividad
el sábado Java también se vio afectada
por un terremoto de magnitud 6,1 menos
de dos semanas después de otro terremoto
mortal que mató a más de 300 personas
el archipiélago se encuentra en el
cinturón de fuego El Pacífico por lo que
los terremotos y erupciones volcánicas
como estas son habituales
en otras noticias nuestra enviada
especial a Ucrania Catalina Gómez Ángel
se encuentra en la ciudad de
turescendoniesk una zona asediada por la
guerra desde que estalló en 2014 Desde
allí nos reporta Cómo vive la población
el recrudecimiento del conflicto
esta ciudad de
ha sido una de esas ciudades que quedó
en la línea de batalla en la división
desde que comenzó la guerra en Ucrania
que recordemos que no fue el 24 de
febrero sino en el 2014 cuando los
grupos separatistas del Don vast ya
peleaban aquí con las tropas ucranianas
Así que aquí se creó una primera línea
de batalla muy pocos metros de aquí
Aunque ellos dicen que durante estos
últimos ocho años habían aprendido a
vivir con esta guerra y bajo la
normalidad pero todo se aceleró el 24 de
febrero mayor batalla mayor presencia de
militares sin embargo también dicen que
poco a poco aprendieron a vivir hasta
los dos últimos meses cuando la batalla
realmente se recrudeció Ellos dicen que
alcanzaron a cerrar durante tres frentes
temían de que la ciudad fuera rodeada y
aislada por las tropas rusas sin embargo
los militares desplegados a este lugar
lograron rep y de tener este avance y
hoy estas tropas han retrocedido otra
vez a enfocarse en la batalla por la
ciudad de Sin embargo ellos también
aseguran que es cada vez la vida es más
difícil y menos población en la ciudad
dicen que no más del 15% de la población
original no solamente por la batalla
sino por las condiciones de vida que no
hay gas no hay agua no hay electricidad
como en el resto de Ucrania y obviamente
temen que este invierno vaya a ser
muchísimo más difícil ayer Solo dos
misiles caían en el mercado local aunque
dicen que Afortunadamente no hubo
víctimas
y mientras continúan los bombardeos
rusos sobre las infraestructuras
energéticas de Ucrania los combates
continúan en el frente sobre todo en el
este del país veamos a continuación la
situación en un hospital de la ciudad de
bakmuth epicentro actual de los combates
estos camilleros ucranianos llevan a un
soldado herido está siendo tratado Con
urgencia aquí los heridos se pueden
contar por docenas
los más graves son operados directamente
estábamos en una trinchera cuando la
artillería empezó a apuntarnos era un
lanzagranadas automático creo
atacados redoblan sus esfuerzos los que
pueden hacerlo disfrutan de un momento
de respiro
troje estaba
[Música]
últimamente se ha vuelto más peligroso
porque los combates están cada vez más
cerca pero seguimos trabajando como
antes
Se desconoce el número de muertos y
heridos de ambos bandos el frente de 40
kilómetros de blackmud es ahora el
principal objetivo de la artillería rusa
en Ucrania
desde este verano se ha concentrado en
esta ciudad del Don vas en busca de la
Victoria tras las derrotas contra el
ejército ucraniano en el sur sin embargo
según la inteligencia estadounidense la
intensidad de los combates en todo el
país ha bajado un poco en las últimas
semanas y la tendencia podría ser aún
más pronunciada
Esperamos que el conflicto se ralentice
en los próximos meses gran parte de los
combates que tienen lugar actualmente en
la zona de bakuta y donnietzk se han
ralentizado desde La retirada rusa de
gerson Oriental
Washington prevé una reanudación de las
contraofensivas rusas y ucranianas en la
próxima Primavera Aunque duda de la
capacidad de Moscú para mantener el
ritmo de reabastecimiento y equipamiento
que se necesitaría para entonces
cambiamos de información este domingo el
presidente de Sudáfrica siriel rama fosa
acusado de corrupción aseguró que Su
futuro depende del comité ejecutivo de
su partido El Congreso Nacional africano
la oposición del movimiento africano de
transformación acusa al mandatario de
incumplir la Constitución que prohíbe al
gobierno desempeñar otras actividades
remuneradas Más allá de su cargo público
una norma que según estableció un panel
independiente rama fosa habría violado
al declarar que el dinero que le fue
robado de su granja en 2020 provenía de
la venta de animales de presa el
presidente sudafricano informó que
impugnará el informe del panel ante la
justicia mientras el comité de su
partido tomará mañana la decisión final
sobre el futuro de ramafosa
y este sábado burkina faso suspendió de
forma inmediata la retransmisión de
radio France internacional rfi nuestra
emisora hermana las autoridades
militares del país acusan a la radio de
dar voz a militantes de una organización
afiliada a al qaeda y de emitir informes
falsos sobre el gobierno recordemos que
en un momento de deterioro de las
relaciones entre París y las colonias
francesas de África occidental burkina
faso no es el primer país en censurar a
medios públicos franceses la junta
militar de Mali ya expulsó a rfi y a
France 24 en marzo rfi por su parte
calificó las acusaciones de las
autoridades burkinesas de infundadas y
aseguró que buscará la manera de
restablecer la retransmisión
y ahora vamos con información del
mundial de fútbol de Qatar porque en
segunda fecha de octavos Francia se sumó
a Argentina y Países Bajos y se
clasifica cuartos de final tras vencer
3-1 a Polonia en el segundo partido del
día se enfrentarán Inglaterra y senegal
conectamos ahora con nuestro enviado
especial a Qatar Juan pupiales Juan
buenas tardes para usted Cuál es la
expectativa ante este encuentro cuál es
el ambiente allá en Qatar
poco ambiente en ese estadio de albed
todavía el estadio más lejano que
tenemos en esta copa mundo lo que sí
sabemos es que Inglaterra y senegal ya
saben quién nos esperaría en ese cruce
de cuartos de final sería la Francia de
kilian mbappé tenemos ya alineaciones
confirmadas para este partido entre
ingleses y senegaleses con Inglaterra un
cambio en el ataque el ingreso de
bucayosaka El delantero del Arsenal en
reemplazo de Marcus por el delantero del
Manchester United bocayo saca que estará
acompañado por Harry kane y foden en la
delantera no cuenta este partido el
seleccionador
Sterling quien aparece ausente en la
lista de convocatorias según reportes
por razones familiares con senegal
también hay cambios o uno obligado en la
medular el de quien acumula
amonestaciones en su lugar entra nanpali
respecto a la victoria contra Ecuador
también hay otro cambio en la modular el
ingreso de diata en lugar de papel
Inglaterra que llega este partido
sabiendo que fueron finalistas en la
pasada Eurocopa semifinalistas en Rusia
2018 se miden Eso sí ante los campeones
de África pero la historia las
estadísticas están de su favor en siete
enfrentamientos previos con selecciones
africanas los ingleses nunca han perdido
Juan y otro tema del mundial han
trascendido novedades sobre el estado de
salud de Neymar
compareció el seleccionador tita en la
rueda de prensa previa al partido de
este lunes y octavos de final contra
Corea del Sur dijo el seleccionador que
confía en que Neymar esté disponible
para este partido para este partido
después de recuperarse de esa elección
en su tobillo derecho que sufrió en el
encuentro inaugural en esa Victoria
contra Serbia dijo tita que iba a
esperar a lo que viera en el
entrenamiento que celebró hasta hace
unas horas Brasil aquí ya en la noche de
Qatar en la víspera de ese partido
contra el combinado asiático afirmó tite
que si Neymar se encuentra bien y él lo
pondría de inicialista afirmó que si un
jugador está en buenas condiciones
físicas debe comenzar desde el inicio
Juan Muchas gracias por el reporte
continuaremos conectando al arco de la
jornada
y nosotros cerramos en la ciudad
francesa de estrasburgo porque este
domingo fue escenario de un inusual
desfile navideño una quincena de papás
de anuel desfilaron por los canales del
centro de estrasburgo en pádel una
novedad que sorprendió a Los visitantes
llegados desde distintos puntos de
Francia para visitar el mercado de
Navidad más popular del país y con estas
imágenes llegamos nosotros al final de
esta edición informativa a ustedes
Muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos
enseguida volvemos
[Música]